buonasera buonasera a tutti io avevo un
sogno che si è realizzato e che vorrei
condividere con voi oggi qui è il sogno
dell'internet delle cose sottomarina
dell'internet l'underwater since
dell'internet degli abissi una sfida
tecnologica che fino a qualche anno fa
sembrava degno di un romanzo di
fantascienza per le difficoltà
intrinseche nello sviluppare tecnologie
affidabili in grado di operare
efficacemente e affidabilmente in un
dominio naturale così ostile e difficile
da raggiungere per l'uomo
eppure scoprire tramite sensori e robot
sottomarini connessi in rete fra loro le
meraviglie di questo mondo è qualcosa di
intrinsecamente legato al nostro modo di
essere uomini
cosa distingue l'uomo dalle altre specie
viventi la sua naturale curiosità da
quando siamo bambini
abbiamo un naturale curiosità nella
nostra voglia di conoscere di superare
le attuali barriere della conoscenza
ciascuno
nasce un po esploratore e in realtà
negli ultimi 25 anni e le tecnologie
anno ci hanno permesso di superare molte
di queste barriere sembra quasi che con
l'internet of things le tecnologie
satellitari ormai niente sia più ignoto
attorno a noi
bene questo è vero ma ci dimentichiamo
cui due terzi del nostro pianeta coperti
d'acqua ea questo desiderio di scoperta
trova la sua massima espressione in
queste tecnologie di cui parlerò oggi
l'internet on the water takes il mondo
marino è un mondo che ha sempre
affascinato esploratori scrittori
ricercatori negli ultimi cinque secoli
se pensiamo a leonardo 12 lo scienziato
di riferimento diciamo in forse l'idea
stessa dello scienziato lo stereotipo di
vedere la stessa dello scienziato
cinque secoli fa leonardo da vinci nel
suo codice atlantico vergò il primo
disegno di una macchina in grado di
portare un uomo sotto la superficie del
mare e non riuscivo ovviamente a
realizzarla era un'idea veramente
fantascientifica a quei tempi ma un
secolo dopo qualche ma ci riuscì
consentendo all'uomo per la prima volta
di esplorare i fondali del tamigi
davanti in inghilterra a giorgio prima e
da allora è cominciata una vera e
propria corsa alla scoperta del mare che
poi ha coinvolto tantissimi scienziati
esploratori scrittori che veramente sono
i nostri asta citati e che hanno dato
dei contributi veramente notevole
all'immaginario collettivo relativo a
questo mondo così misterioso una
ovviamente e jules verne con i suoi
20.000 le sue ventimila leghe sotto al
mare di cui vedete qui
una frase che è molto significativa
perché ci ricorda il ruolo che questo
ambiente l'ambiente marino svolge nella
nostra vita
il diciamo i mari oceani laghi coprono
oltre due terzi del nostro pianeta
svolgono un ruolo essenziale nella
circolazione dell'ossigeno e ospitano la
maggior parte di specie viventi sul
nostro pianeta conosciute e molto
probabilmente non ne conosciamo perché
in realtà i nostri sensi non arrivano al
di là del confine della superficie del
mare
quindi è semplicemente un ambito che
conosciamo poco pochissimo per la verità
qui vedete rappresentato il nostro
pianeta dello spazio quale miglior
evidenza per renderci conto che anche se
siamo abituati all'ambito terrestre
la maggior parte del nostro pianeta è
coperto da sé che conosciamo ben molto
meno dei lontani pianeti come marte
negli ultimi anni sapete tutti ci sono
state delle incredibili scoperte siamo
stati in grado di mandare diversi lander
su marte qui vedete un collage di alcune
foto riprese questi renderanno mandato
migliaia di foto relative a marte sono
stati presi vari campioni e come per
marte anche per altri pianeti
quali
augurio venere la nasa ha fatto varie
missioni che hanno permesso di mappare
eppure se pensiamo al nostro pianeta di
quei due terzi del pianeta coperti
d'acqua noi conosciamo solo il 5 per
cento
in questo momento quindi quello che un
ambiente marina e la vera frontiera
della scoperta e la vera frontiera
dell'esplorazione che ancora ci rimane
da affrontare perché è così importante è
importante perché questo ambiente ha
dentro di sé le risposte essenziali per
il nostro futuro
se pensiamo ai grossi temi che noi i
nostri figli dovremo affrontare nei
prossimi decenni quali ad esempio cibo
per un'umanità che continua a crescere
quale ad esempio come affrontare come
risolvere il problema del cambiamento
climatico come ad esempio come ottenere
le risorse naturali che servono per lo
sviluppo della nostra indosso e tutti
grossissimi temi ebbene molti di queste
domande richiedono per la loro risposta
una comprensione una conoscenza e
potenzialmente lo sfruttamento
sostenibile delle risorse offerte dai
mari e degli oceani e quindi come avete
sentito parlare già più volte
dell'internet state dell'internet delle
cose attorno a noi per l'idea è quella
di estendere la capacità di monitoraggio
dell'internet delle cose anche
all'ambiente marino perché è una cosa
così difficile da realizzare per in
realtà non possiamo utilizzare nessuna
delle tecnologie utilizzate per
l'ambiente terrestre
le onde radio ad esempio che ci
permettono interconnettere tutti i
dispositivi attorno a noi nelle nostre
smart city non si possano propagare
nell'ambiente marina e quindi cosa
dobbiamo fare dobbiamo utilizzare il
metodo di comunicazione utilizzate
selezionato dai mammiferi marini milioni
di anni le comunicazioni acustiche e
questo porta tantissime sfide che vedete
illustrate in questo video
in particolare abbiamo bisogno di
realizzare sensori particolari in grado
di operare nelle profondità marine di
misura le varie parametri quali la
temperatura la serenità le correnti il
ph per comprendere l'acidificazione
degli oceani e robot sottomarini che
possono essere dispiegati facilmente da
un gommone come quello da cui andiamo
con cui andiamo in vacanza possono
scoprire gli uni gli altri
creare una rete di comunicazione
scambiarsi senza fili le informazioni in
tempo reale per poter agire come una
squadra e insieme sotto il controllo
dell'uomo svolgere dei compiti complessi
che sarebbe stato impossibile svolgere
fino ad adesso o che sarebbe stato
estremamente complesso costoso e
pericoloso per l'uomo svolgere aprendo
delle possibilità incredibile per la
scoperta dei fondali marini per la
scoperta di questo mondo fornendoci la
possibilità di estendere i nostri sensi
al di là di quello che un confine fisico
al di là di quello che è il confine
della superficie marina quello vedete in
una sperimentazione reale che abbiamo
fatto
affascinante perché in realtà si tratta
del supporto a degli archeologi che nel
in un sito archeologico sommerso in
italia a marzamemi in sicilia hanno
avuto la possibilità di utilizzare un
team di questi robot sottomarini per
scoprire nuovi reperti in realtà una
delle maggiori soddisfazioni e stato
proprio il fatto che ci siamo riusciti
in un sito che era stato scavato ben
noto siamo riusciti a trovare nuovi
reperti grazie alla possibilità di
estendere i nostri sensi alla
possibilità di rocco sul maghetto
sottomarini di vedere quello che c'era
al di là del fondale
se andiamo la prossima grazie a come
sanno per esempio che non ci sono solo i
sottomarini lo vedete qui rappresentate
ora i robot sottomarini nella prossima
slide e qui vedete una bellissima
colonna romana di fama che faceva parte
del sito di marzamemi che
citavo prima l'aspetto essenziale è il
fatto che l'uomo è al centro
queste tecnologie ci permettono di
superare i nostri confini fisici ma
siamo noi che dobbiamo sfruttare
tecnologie come sensore i robot
sottomarini per la nostra fase di
scoperta e poi queste tecnologie possono
anche essere utilizzate per consentirci
una di sperimentare in maniera più ricca
la nostra dimensione all'interno del
mondo marino quindi possono aumentare la
sicurezza dei suv fornendo informazioni
in tempo reale sullo stato diciamo delle
di sicurezza del sub stesso o come in
questa foto con la foto reale possono
consentire all'uomo di condividere
informazioni sui social anche mentre sta
facendo un'immersione è anche una
bellissima storia credo contro gli
stereotipi
innanzitutto una storia di ricerca al
femminile perché si basa su un'idea
femminile
io sono molto fiera di far parte di
questo progetto 100 donne contro gli
stereotipi che sollecita le giovani
donne
a seguire la passione di tante donne
impegnate nella scienza e tecnologia è
anche una storia di giovani di giovani
dotati di talento energia che hanno
fatto loro questo sogno
questa visione questo entusiasmo e hanno
deciso di dedicare le loro vite qui alla
realizzazione di questa sfida
tecnologica
una storia contro gli stereotipi perché
una storia di cervelli rientrati e da
una storia di cervelli come i miei
ragazzi ragazzi del mio gruppo senza i
quali non sarebbero ma avremmo mai
raggiunto questi obiettivi che avevano
avuto tante opportunità all'estero a che
hanno scelto invece di realizzare
pienamente le loro aspirazioni di
carriera qui in italia è una storia d
europa che per una volta veramente dal
valore perché è una storia di una
ricerca che è stata finanziata negli
anni grazie alla vittoria di fondi
competitivi europee e in particolare
l'ultimo finanziamento che abbiamo preso
un finanziamento
della cosiddetta european agency for sm
agenzia europea per l'innovazione le
piccole e medie imprese
quindi questo ha consentito anche di
creare una spin off della sapienza in
cui questi giovani di cui vi raccontavo
stanno mettendo le loro energie per
portare realmente nel mondo reale che ho
detto mercato le soluzioni che abbiamo
sviluppato all'interno di un progetto
quale archeo sub che mette insieme due
aspetti del nostro essere italiani beni
culturali e tecnologia quindi sviluppare
tecnologie per il monitoraggio e la
sorveglianza la verifica dello stato di
conservazione e la valorizzazione dei
beni archeologici sommersi oltre mille
attorno alle coste dell'italia non
sfruttati e non sorvegliati è una storia
quindi di made in italy un po diverso
non si tratta della pasta non si tratta
della nutella non si tratta del design
di tecnologie che nascono da qui che
sono sviluppate qui e che poi esportiamo
con tante richieste da industrie essere
da governi as he perché perché queste
tecnologie sono al cuore di un
cambiamento paradigmatico nella blue
economy l'economia del mare è sempre più
le risorse che ci servono
vengono da questo mondo se pensiamo al
cibo per un'economia per una umanità che
cresce se pensiamo ai cosmetici
se pensiamo alle medicina ok moltissime
di queste alle risorse naturali e
minerali preziosi moltissimo di quello
che ci serve piano ormai dall'ambiente
marino ed è un economia che vale
centinaia di miliardi di euro 5 milioni
di posti di lavoro nella sola europa in
cui in questo momento siamo protagonisti
di un cambiamento tecnologico per
rendere più competitiva questa economia
per abbassare i costi per aumentare
quello che può essere fatto per
sfruttare in modo sostenibile l'ambiente
marino
quali sono le applicazioni
potenzialmente infinite da comprendere
questo mondo e quindi comprendere
veramente la tettonica del nostro
pianeta
diciamo fenomeni come il vulcanismo
in ambito sottomarino ha potere in
maniera efficace controllare i nostri
confini marittimi a reagire nel momento
in cui avvengono di disastri naturali o
eventi come il naufragio della costa con
su concordia inoltre lo sviluppo di
sistemi per il monitoraggio e
l'ottimizzazione per esempio
dell'acquacultura centinaia di miliardi
di euro di nuovo è qualcosa che è
essenziale per poter offrire il cibo che
serve a l'umanità del futuro
inoltre il monitoraggio delle fasi di
estrazione nelle fasi di trasporto di
petrolio gas naturale o il monitoraggio
di infrastrutture marine quali porti
oppure ancora il mondo meraviglioso
veramente affascinante dell'archeologia
marina gusto diceva che nel momento in
cui ha avuto la possibilità di vedere
nel mare la sua vita non è stata più la
stessa non ha più potuto concepire la
vita pensare vivere nello stesso modo
con questa frase ha condiviso con noi un
emozione nel momento in cui è stato in
grado di superare i suoi limiti e ora
noi io vorrei io il mio gruppo vorremmo
condividere con voi oggi questa emozione
di aver sviluppato tecnologie che
permetteranno alla prossima generazione
di esploratore quindi l'uomo al centro
nel 2030 di poter fino in fondo
esplorare questa parte così grande del
nostro pianeta e spero che magari alcuni
dei giovani esploratori siano fra i
vostri ragazzi i vostri bambini proprio
qui da foggia grazie
[Applauso]